(mellow jingle)
(audience cheers)
- Hi.
- Well, we got a lot of woos
It's lovely,
- [Man] I'll take it,
that's nice.
- It's lovely to meet you.
Have y'all ever met before?
- We haven't.
- I don't think we have.
- [Kelly] Y'all haven't
met before?
- No, yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm just like Jesus.
- But I'm a big fan, so this
- [Kelly] bringing people
- is exciting for me too
- Oh, wow, fantastic,
so great to meet you.
- So nice to meet you too.
- I don't know anybody that isn't a fan.
Like especially, Dwight,
yeah, I'm just saying,
we all aware from those shirts.
- That is true, that is true.
- So, we,
(Kelly and Shane chuckle)
So, we are all musical here.
I just learned of bassoon skills.
- Well, I pretend, but yes I try.
- You pretend?
- I try.
- No, you have a band.
- I do, I do.
Yes, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] So your band, Twilight Creeps.
- [Shane] That's right, yeah.
- So it has been called horror rock.
So what does that mean?
- It's kinda like,
I'm a big fan of The Misfits.
- Okay.
- A little Danzig back in the day,
and I'm a big fan of Halloween in general
and any sort of-
- I love dressing up.
- scary movies and dressing up
- I'm just not into that-
- and all that stuff.
- Okay, right, well-
- Scary movies, nope.
- I love scary movies, so we kinda
- Really?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Like the, like what kind?
Like you like to be jumped out at
or like gore or like?
- All of the above.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- I was tortured when I was a kid.
I saw "Nightmare on Elm
Street" (Kelly gasps)
when I was six years old.
- That, that's what sent me the other way.
(audience laughs)
- And it sent me the other way.
Yeah, it was the, I mean I ,
- It's like the original
Edward Scissorhand
and I was not into it, yeah.
- That's right
and he kills you in your sleep.
It's not, you can't
run away from that.
- In a water bed yeah,
you gotta be careful.
- Water bed. That's right.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, yes.
- So that kind of, it, that all
made me kind of more excited
I guess, in a weird way.
- Oh, my God.
- And I, we decided to put a
band together that was based
off of our love of horror
movies and things like that.
And we chose the, the song title
from a great band called
Cricket Fingers and
and we gave it a shot, yeah.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- So your new, your new movie,
like your music has a bit
of horror as well, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I sense a theme.
- Yeah. There's a theme, I have a little
toxic apparently too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I sense a theme.
- I know this is a little
outta control right now.
This should be for Halloween.
It's called Mid-century
and it, it was just
I actually helped produce this,
it's something that I wanna try
and get into as well.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- It's a, it's a married couple,
one a doctor, one a lawyer
that are having their
their issues in married life.
And they get a mid-century Airbnb home,
for a weekend to kind of
get through their issues
and their problems and things like that.
- A getaway.
- Yeah.
- But then they find out, rather quickly,
that the place is haunted.
And then they also find out,
a little bit later that
besides it being haunted,
there's also possibly someone who's alive
in the Airbnb watching them as well.
- Whoa.
- And then it spirals
outta control with that.
I'm not sure I can explain too much more
because it goes very David Lynch'ian, but
- But do they get their refund back?
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You'll have to watch.
- [Kelly] Or do.
- Somebody does, but I can't,
- Do they make it out? That's my question.
- Somebody does, but I can't
say who, it's that kinda thing.
- Okay.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah (chuckles)
- So you, so you, you
own a Tex Mex restaurant
and I've actually been there.
- [Shane] Oh yeah.
- It's so good.
- Oh, good. I'm glad.
- It's called Justin Queso.
- [Shane] Thank you.
- Do you?
- Oh my God, Justin Queso?
- I love this.
- I love a good pun
name. That's fantastic.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- It's pretty great. I wish
I could take credit for it,
but I can't.
- I know, and you go in
and so like here it's awesome for me
because I'm Texan and
like anybody Texan coming
there's all this like
memorabilia, Willie Nelson,
it's all like, it's so cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] And I really dig it.
- Oh, good, good, I'm glad.
- Yes. And the queso good. How do rate it?
- Okay, so I'm a Louisiana
boy so I kind of had to
- [Kelly] Step back,
- to, you know,
you guys let me know how this is going.
- Okay.
- They're all Texans
that's like actually
involved behind the scenes
besides myself.
- Yeah.
- But to me queso always
good, but I wasn't 'cause,
I hadn't been taught.
- Blasphemy.
(audience chuckles)
- I hadn't been taught.
I hadn't been taught.
And now I know what's good and what's not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thanks to this restaurant
- [Kelly] Y'all's is good.
- Okay, good, I love that.
- Yeah, I loved it I.
I was so, I walked in there going,
"okay Justin, Justin Queso."
(audience and Shane chuckle)
I was like a real Texan
was walking in Tex Mex
I was like this is gonna be.
- And it's on
Sunset Boulevard, let's
see how that works.
- I know. I was like
- West Hollywood.
- "good try Hollywood" and then
I was like, ate a vat of it.
It was so good, yes.
- Oh good, love that.
- Wait, I love your queso so
much, I know you've had it,
but I didn't know if you'd had it.
So I brought it all for all of
us. Cause I really selfishly,
- Oh my god.
- Ooh.
- just wanted it.
- That's what was,
(audience claps)
okay alright.
- I really just wanted it.
Thank you, Justin.
- Oh, fabulous, thank you.
- You gotta try it.
- Let's see how, I was
- Oh, it's not runny,
it's been sitting,
- gonna say it's been sitting
waiting for me to shut up.
- Oh wow.
- Wait, it's been sitting
so usually its runny.
- I'm still doing it.
- Better finish this off "Justin Queso".
(all laugh)
- No, when you go there, it's runnier,
I just wouldn't shut up,
so it like, you know sat.
- Well, that's nice.
- It's not bad.
- It's so good.
- Mm. Mm.